well within about 20 minutes you started
seeing stories in the usual propaganda
outlets claiming the president hates our
troops
criticized the pentagon and you hate the
troops
no one's writing stories like that about
joe biden biden has been a defender of
the defense industry for decades back in
2003 he was an avid defender of the
invasion of iraq
some of my own party have said it was a
mistake to go to iraq in the first place
the cost of not acting against saddam i
think would have been much greater
and so is the cost and so will be the
cost
of not finishing this job
so under biden presidency
our foreign policy is likely to change
and the question is
how well in may joe biden's foreign
policy advisor gave us a preview of that
he's a man called tony blinken
he said he considers america's military
presence in syria to be quote
leverage and
the extent the united states had any
remaining leverage in syria to try to
effectuate
some more positive outcome unfortunately
the trump administration has more or
less torn that up too
pulling out entirely
in syria has taken away significant
leverage
significant leverage well turns out we
haven't pulled out of syria in fact we
learned today that there are more
american troops in syria
than any of us knew the pentagon
apparently lied to the administration
about that so we're not leaving syria
because it's leverage are we ever
leaving afghanistan
apparently the administration is trying
to pull out in the next month is it
going to work